joining us now for reaction is Jeff Bell
the president of the Broward County
Sheriff's deputy's Association as well
as mark fuhrman who's a former LAPD
detective and a fox news contributor
gentlemen it's good to see you mark
let's start with you it was it was
chilling to watch the surveillance video
and also to listen both to the students
9-1-1 calls and to the to the old 911
calls that Cruz himself made and that
Cruz's caretaker at the time had made
your reaction to the new developments
well when I watch the video Laura the
thing that really strikes me is watching
Peterson look at the building not look
at the area outside of the building he
knew what the shots were coming from the
building he stood there and he listened
for four to five minutes
as probably as many as 17 18 20 people
were shot inside and he did nothing so I
watch him in that video I don't think he
was mentally or physically prepared for
the job I don't think he probably ever
was he lost his nerve if he ever had any
he lost it and there's really no excuse
for it except for I think one thing is
there was probably a lack of training
and leadership on that Sheriff's
Department coming right down from
sheriff Israel right down to Scott
Peterson Jeff you have spoken about this
before the utter lack of time and focus
on training for the exact type of
situation that Marc was analyzing there
in an active shooter it has to be muscle
memory you just know what to do and you
have to train for it repeatedly and
often to be able to respond in the right
way I mean most people do so what do you
know about the training at Broward we
know what the manual says and I'm gonna
get to that in a minute but what
actually took place well Laura I would
think that in Broward County I could sum
this up as the best with a law
enforcement community we viewed this as
the perfect storm coming and
unfortunately 17 people lost their lives
in parkland that day for a series events
that we consider to be
bad policy the wrong priorities and
training the politicizing of our police
forces down here and the bad
implementation of deals that we've made
with the school board with the promise
program in civil citation and what I
mean by training when I go back to that
is that our trainers do a wonderful job
with the limited resources that they
have with the Broward Sheriff's Office
but what we need to do is focus the
resources that we have on better tactics
and better training for example we spend
in in-service training eight hours
mandatory in-service training in
de-escalation tactics and then we spend
another eight hours in politeness and
policing tactics to be nicer to people
that were arresting but when it comes
time to practicing on the gun range in
practicing scenarios we dedicate four
hours of training on the gun range where
we may SWE's off about a hundred and
fifty rounds and then two hours of
practice with simulation on that the
wrong emphasis is being put on
politicizing the police department and
not training properly for these
scenarios it is out of control and we
have to stop this okay the the
politeness training I think I may be I
need some politeness training here
because I'm being tough one Scott Israel
but here's the Broward County Sheriff's
Office training manual okay here's one
full screen the first officer or two
officers on scene will immediately go to
confront the shooter military tactics
work well in this situation also another
part of it remember every time you hear
a gunshot in an active shooter incident
you have to believe that another victim
is being killed mark you know this well
with all your experience in LA PD
something isn't adding up here we're
getting reports and we're still doing
actual investigation on this reports
from retired officers mark who say that
because of the way the patronage system
with that Scott Israel has an effect
there we got a lot of people in place
with inadequate experience to do the
jobs they're supposed to be doing
inadequate experience but they got a
connection because a friend of a friend
giving it a good donation to his
campaign and it and it doesn't look good
on the surface it doesn't look good
your reaction well this is this is the
problem when you have a politicized law
enforcement agency when you have an
elected official calling the shots
that quite possibly is a competent
police officer or he could just be a
civilian that becomes sheriff but when
you start using nepotism to fill your
ranks or favors or paying somebody back
for their contributions or their support
during a campaign it's the kiss of death
this is a leadership problem and as far
as what Jeff was saying about training
level one of those beautiful golf
courses down in Florida and make a range
for the officers a county wide a state
range this is this is where the rubber
meets the road and as far as suspects
and being nice when they say you're
under arrest it's up to the suspect to
determine what happens after that if
they want to play hard then you play
harder that class just lasted 30 seconds
it's over you need to focus all your
attention on the threat and the deadly
threat not only to the officer but to
civilians and citizens that are
completely unknowing of the threat in
front of them officers know it and they
should train for it and they should
train for specific incidents just like
parkland Jeff I have to ask you about
these calls that a lot of people haven't
really focused on but that November late
November call to 911
we had Nicholas Cruz himself call saying
oh I was kicked out of the house I'm
staying and I got into a fight with
someone I was punching a wall and then
the the MS Deschamps who actually had
taken in Nicholas Cruz whose son got
into the fight with him she says on that
911 call that we just played he has held
a gun to his his brother's head before
and to his dead mother said who it just
recently died so this was nothing new
for him to threaten someone by holding a
gun to his head at that point and you
both can address this how does the
police not act on that knowing that she
says he's going to get a gun at Dick's
Sporting Goods and she's basically said
I'm very worried about that and then she
doesn't decide to press charges
afterward because she felt bad for him
or whatever but couldn't the police have
acted right at that moment well or down
here in Broward County with the law
enforcement officers all of that was
removed out of our hands with the civil
citation
program in a promise program whether
it's on the school or out on the street
for these misdemeanor crimes we don't
have the ability to arrest these
juveniles and bring him down to the
juvenile hall under arrest charges on
that he's 19 years older tied not
juvenile he's 19 correct he is 19 now
but we've created this sense of
empowerment to allow mr. Cruz and other
people like this to get to this point
where nothing has happened in their life
and now we've created this problem right
I get that but mark my point is at that
point when his guardian essentially says
he's he's pointing a gun at it my son
and then his mother and then his brother
and he's going to get a weapon could the
police at that point have done something
and should they have yes they could have
then it's it's a felony it's assault
with a deadly wound of [ __ ] well it's
not a misdemeanor
I mean brandishing a firearm is a
misdemeanor but when you couple it with
a threat a visible or a verbal threat
then it's a salt with a deadly weapon
you have a victim it's an arrest bull
offense and at the very least you get
the weapons out of the house you arrest
the juvenile you get him into the system
get him in front of a detective a social
worker you get him into juvenile hall
and if he's an adult you get him into
jail and have a detective talk to him
you do what you can you get all the guns
everything that he has then and you take
it I mean it's there are so many things
that were red flags here flares
fireworks the fact that none of them
added up to an intervention that stopped
this is really stunning and none of this
was discussed at the rallies yesterday
it was all Donald Trump's bad and get
the guns I mean that's all we were
talking about we weren't talking about
any of this and I know the other line is
convenient great segment guys thank you
so much up next yeah go ahead no no I
just want to say they're always looking
for an excuse not to do something in
certain instances it's a female it's a
mental patient it's a drug addict it's a
child they're looking for a reason not
to do something not to do something
because it's difficult complicated and
time-consuming and they might get sued
right or they might get disciplined or
they
I not get supported by the sheriff
that's another thing that they're
worried about everyone's worried about
getting sued and having their lives
turned upside down and so the police are
some of them are damned if they do they
damned if they don't it's a terrible
situation